last week Donald Trump called me and he
said uh any advice on who I should pick
for vice president really who do you
think not that he I mean he's probably
calling everyone but that's great that
you're on that list and so he said who
do you think and I
said I don't know how you're going to
feel about it but this is the day I
think it was the day he trashed vake and
I said v um and he said why do you say
that he said that's the number one
response from everybody I've asked
question and he said why do you say that
and I said a he can defend you he's
right in your pocket and while you're
defending this he's watching your back
defending this I said also um I think
he's some of his ideas are really really
good he connects with the youth which
now the latest uh of 18 to 24 year olds
that voted for Biden